[Music]
okay so if you saw my review of the
first Cheetah Girls you know that I
think it's the worst of these Disney
Channel films I've seen so far so of
course I have to look at Cheetah Girls 2
and well the good news is it's not
nearly as bad why well let's just pick a
random scene here
chill I've tried everything she won't
budge there's a dance camp I can teach
this summer but it's basically
babysitting see what they're doing
they're talking yeah they're not
giggling or streaming or squeeing or
jumping up and down or shouting
cheetalicious are doing a dance number I
don't know where they're actually
shutting the hell up and listening to
one another that makes this film a
million light-years beyond the last one
oh thank heaven Lee Jesus but with that
said does it actually make it good
actually of all things it makes it kind
of boring now don't get me wrong I much
rather take boring over whatever the
hell the last one was but it doesn't
excuse the fact that it's still pretty
dull as you'd expect the Cheetah Girls
are a big hit but it looks like one of
them has to leave to go to Barcelona
because her mother wants to be with her
hopefully soon fiancee who lives there
the Cheetah Girls find out of course
there's a gigantic music contest there
and decide why the hell not they'll go
to something I'll travel to see the
sights or at least take some postcards
I'm assuming they didn't have a budget
to see all the sights and they come
across cute boys do some fun dance
numbers and even discover another girl
entering the contest at first it looks
like her mother is on board with helping
everybody out but oh no she actually
wants to split the Cheetah Girls up why
because one of the Cheetah Girls can
sing in Spanish and her and her daughter
sound really good together so she just
wants it to be the two of them wait a
minute why doesn't she just join the
group
wouldn't that make a lot more sense hey
do whatever so
despite her better judgment the daughter
tries to split the girls up and at first
it seems to work
Galleria gets so fed up that she's
eventually gonna go home but then they
decide no we're all sisters were in it
together and they have the big reunion
song number and everything seems to be
okay all's well that ends well wait a
minute there's still 40 minutes left
what the hell we gonna do with the rest
of that time well some mother tries to
sabotage it
again yeah she sets them up at a club
where they get paid but that
unfortunately means they're
professionals and the head of the
contest finds out and disqualifies them
because it's only for amateurs but it
looks like the girl that speaks Spanish
can still sing with the daughter even
though she's part of the group that was
disqualified she accepted money - why
wouldn't this whatever so they're gonna
sing together with the Cheetah Girls
blessings but then wait a minute the
head of the contest figures out that the
mother was the one who set up the paying
gig knowing it was a paying gig so that
somehow gets them back in what no who
cares let's just end on the inevitable
wedding between the other mother and the
Barcelona guy which focus is very little
on them and instead the Cheetah Girls
singing over their moment yeah really
stealing the thunder from this plot
threat at first the bridesmaids in the
background and that kind of makes sense
but it keeps coming back to them singing
over a pretty landscape like the wedding
is kind of secondary no no it's for the
emotions of these two people our egos
are too big that you have to focus on us
or at least that's how it comes across
that's how a lot of it comes across just
an excuse for them to sing and look
pretty and do dance moves and sometimes
it's okay like I really like this one
scene where they sing this barcelonan
lullaby it's in Spanish and it's really
quiet and it's really nice it's only two
girls singing and yeah that was a nice
change of pace at legit nice moment
there's also a nicely done ballroom
dancing scene where it's only two people
dancing there's not that many special
effects or smoke or lights or
distractions it's just these two people
dancing and they do it really well and
the fast editing and camera movements
here unlike the other times don't get in
the way or distract you it actually
emphasizes what a good job they're doing
little scenes like that aren't bad but
for the most part it's pretty
forgettable I think this is mainly so
kids can just watch it and say oh aren't
I so much like cheetah girl number three
Oh cheetah girl number four it's just
like my personality what if I was there
and if that's something your kids like
to do more power to them but for anyone
else it's not nearly as bad as the first
but it's a definite past
[Music]